Ragazzi, allora è da un pò di giorni, in realtà un pò più di qualche giorno
che penso che vi devo questo video. So che sembra un pò il discorso di Mattarella alla nazione
però è il meglio che siamo riusciti a fare.
Già dal titolo avrete capito un pò di cose, è inutile che ci giri troppo attorno...
Mi sono stufato...
Punto, cioè mi sono stufato.
Io guardo i video che pubblico,
entro su YouTube e mi rompo il c***o.
Mi rompo il c***o di quello che vedo che fanno le persone e dei miei video.
Cioè io vado sul mio canale e pian piano
vedo proprio la luce della felicità
che pian piano se ne va dai miei occhi e finisce nella tomba.
C’è una cosa che mi sono detto,
che è quella di essere non tanto essere onesto con le persone che mi stanno attorno
ma almeno con me stesso.
Non sono soddisfatto, contento.
Non mi riconosco nei contenuti che stanno uscendo.
Il mio problema è legato a YouTube,
io amo troppo questa piattaforma per volerla relegare
a un contenitore dove si produce per produrre
ma poi in realtà si prosegue con il pilota automatico. “Famolo perché va fatto”.
Non è il motivo per cui ho iniziato YouTube
il modo in cui sto lavorando su YouTube
Non è un modo che mi rappresenta.
Ecco io vorrei tornare come vi dicevo ad essere orgoglioso
di quello che posto
almeno io, non dovete esserlo per forza anche voi. Spero che lo siate
Magari in futuro
e allo stesso tempo voglio tornare ad essere libero
perché i brand a volte mettono dei legacci
che bloccano completamente questo tipo di libertà
YouTube non è un posto
che io ho mai vissuto come un posto all'interno del quale fare soldi
E poteri, e quando lo faccio funziona di meno
quando non lo faccio sto meglio io.
Voglio impegnarmi al fine di favorire la qualità alla quantità
prendere una pausa ad agosto
cioè non è che scompaio. Ci saranno magari degli shorts
più leggeri. Su Instagram non è che sparirò
vi farò vedere il bucio di c**o sulla spiaggia, tutte quelle cose
che si fanno su Instagram comunque.
Però io ho bisogno di ritrovarmi un pochino
non so se vi capita anche a voi, io ormai...
al prossimo che becco che mi fa smile without your eyes
raise your eyebrows... sto c***o questa è la model face... to to to
oppure "I see by self
perché sempre più piccoli, ormai appena  partoriranno gli faranno fare
"Talking to the Moon"
e fanno vedere gli occhi dei bambini.. non ce la faccio!
È tutto troppo uguale
E che sia chiaro, sono il primo a essermici divertito
e sono il primo che molto probabilmente mi ci divertirò con questa roba qui
Io ho un amore troppo grande per questa piattaforma
per trasformarla in un posto nel quale posto tanto per postare
YouTube è un posto fluido
è un posto nel quale si può sperimentare, è un posto nel quale
ci si può far conoscere per chi siamo davvero e non per ciò che va di moda
e ciò che tutti gli altri seguono e che fanno
È un posto all'interno del quale si può trovare una propria voce
perché io in passato l'ho trovata
e vorrei continuare ad utilizzarla non tanto per parlare di chissà che cosa
ma per parlare. A volte mi sembra che la voce che esce non sia manco la mia
... ultimamente. So tragico eh, ve lo dico subito
Io voglio potermi meritare la vostra attenzione
Non voglio che sia uno storico di affetto che vi porti a guardare i miei contenuti
Voglio che sia un genuino interesse ma che deve per prima cosa partire da me
Quello che sto dicendo è che voglio andare in una direzione nuova
Non ho ancora la risposta
ma molto probabilmente tante delle cose che avete visto non ci saranno più
magari posto della roba che voi la guardate ed è agghiacciante
e vi mancheranno i momenti più bassi del mio canale
Però voglio essere almeno felice io.
E alcune di queste idee sono state trascinate e prosciugate
troppo a lungo e puoi spremere un limone fino a un certo punto
Quindi, io mi ero scritto delle cose che non ho seguito e che non seguirò
Quello che voglio dirvi è, sia ringraziarvi